[Music]
in nice try news not stop but submitted
by Marcos chief Michael key a woman
tried to get out of a DUI every time
police she's a clean thoroughbred white
girl this is all you showed me last
night funny that's awesome
yeah what is thoroughbred bean I heard
that basic purebred oh oh oh I thought
that man she [ __ ] really hard
oh she's thorough with her breeding I
get it no no because people's a buck
like a thoroughbred alright that too
purebred is supposed to [ __ ] harder like
a stallion I've never heard of that yeah
her of it okay
I heard of it that's all like damn
you're trying to [ __ ] make the cops
horny so you could get away that's what
I always think is girls are trying to
make cops warning you guys do that right
you guys should you just have that
superpower
remember geo tried and then she failed I
did that with me oh that was you is
getting worse and worse is while I know
it might actually be getting better
because at least both of your Mexican so
like there's something there's a
connection there and you're both two
girls in this room though so I'm ready
to sure you know if you got pulled over
and then you try to would suck dick
what are you like batting your eyes
that's all I did pretty much
and then what did the cop do Jeff's not
being there [ __ ] eye man no like I
was
because I don't know how to flirt like
to for my advantage just like this yeah
I don't know I've never I've never
really done that that like the first and
only time so I'm like man every time
you're pulled over I always get a ticket
I want to see what you say though when
you thought it though I feel like you're
saying like the most awkward thing she's
like hi officer do you ever sometimes
just like feel awkward first date
question yeah what do you what do you
mean what do you what are you talking
about where you from and it's like well
obviously I'm from here yeah Mike
because we're here that signal
originally so I'm from Los Angeles no
but see that's actual flirting I was not
doing any of that you want to look at my
elbow even all I did was [ __ ] I'm
getting pulled over it's a dude pulled
out my lipstick put some lipstick on and
I'm like and that was it well you're not
exerting sexuality you you sound like a
13 year old learning I don't know how to
be a seductive woman have you started
cuz you got the lipstick that's good
that's my boobs a little bit okay right
when the window rolls down you should
already have a cylindrical object in
your mouth you should just roll the wall
the window with your fist in your mouth
[Laughter]
all right he's like he's like oh I get
it
officer I'm sorry was I speeding I was
too busy deepthroating my water bottle I
can get it I can really get it down my
throat if I speed and then I hit the
brakes
yeah no ticket for you ever mm-hmm yeah
the officer would give himself a ticket
after that exactly no I know for next
time first time so this woman this woman
her name is Lauren she was pulled over I
am Lauren yeah she was clearly driving
while intoxicated her blood alcohol
level was 18% oh [ __ ] oh dude
ATM sorry oh I was like
no matter what she said this woman
should not have to pay any price she's
like a [ __ ] bottle of baka
I forgot the point that's like those
commercials where they open the door and
like nothing but alcohol comes out
that's what she was in is that car that
[ __ ] went to the lake and you open
[Laughter]
Donald Duck your son yourself exactly
what the hiccups I did you get the papa
it's a good party Dumbo with those pink
[ __ ] things going around yeah yeah so
she started saying that she was a
cheerleader she was a dancer a sorority
girl who graduated from a highly
accredited university just trying to
tell officer that she's down a [ __ ]
she's putting it in cars it's all the
[ __ ] stereotypes sorority cheerleader
all those things like I want to [ __ ] my
way out of this thing well I mean she
also repeatedly said that her partner is
a cop and that she was trying to get to
her boyfriend's house oh she's just
saying that I [ __ ] cops even porn tropes
she's doing porn truck [ __ ] God excuse
me officer yeah and then that she also
said that she was a white thoroughbred
and that she went on to say she's a
white clean girl and then though what
does a white girl bright like not Jewish
not Irish not Scottish
Street much so whatever mean what is
considered zero and real white not
Italian not Irish the real light I'm
like what are those Norwegian whites no
looks like let's put it very simply
she's like one of the royal family
oh there's no mixing because if there
was somebody died and they took it right
out of the bloodline if you were a cop
it all said that [ __ ] to you you're
single by the way okay would you take
the offer yes 100% there you go my man
you know why cuz I'm a man how would you
you know why cuz I'm a man with power
and authority yep and if ya and if I
need that kind of power and authority
you better believe I mix boy
what would you do unzip your pabts and
put it through the [ __ ] window and
she'll start sucking like this I think
probably out boy first you got to turn
off the [ __ ] camera behind you
because why do cops forget to ever get
caught it's a you know you had the dash
cam [ __ ] disabled maybe they can't
disable it well then you don't [ __ ] the
girl's mouth and then no in the in the
dash cam you don't think I would do that
Gesell in the officer was asking cuz he
was also white he was like what does
that have to do with anything and she
was like well you're a cop you should
know what that means
see that's hot code she's first of all
she's drunk
that's [ __ ] you got like you know what
that means you want to get your [ __ ]
cop [ __ ] sucked yeah see that three
times long [ __ ] sucked [ __ ] [ __ ] sucked
[ __ ] [ __ ] sucked yeah then uh officers
found weed and rolling papers in her
Ford Fusion so she's a little bit
Jamaican did that turn you on her for
fusion yeah yeah that was actually the
part where I was like you gotta go now
yeah cuz she says she only had two wine
two glasses of wine she was old and I
hate the Ford Fusion by the way how dare
you that is a terrible car okay what
element wins I'm soon I'm assuming what
happened was the cop went on reddit and
did one of these posts or like he went
on Facebook oh my god today at work this
is what happened yeah what did why he's
in his uniform
that's hot picturing because like who
else would have told this store had to
be Facebook yeah most of the time I
don't even know how these stories come
to light
isn't that a picture though see this
thoroughbred white chick oh yeah or the
department was talking about it why sure
that's exactly what I was why is she so
greasy she said she was cleaned she's
not clean actually saying this there's
clear evidence that it's not you know
d-beam I think there's real thoroughbred
white people looking at this and saying
huh you're not one of them that's one of
us yeah the Queen would be like Oh
dreadful
somewhere didn't nobody forgot to
mention the reason why she got pulled
over though uh she ran a stop she ran a
stop sign at 60 miles per it holy father
killed somebody 60 yeah that's [ __ ]
bad dude that's pretty bad you just know
getting out of that but if you are
running a stop you kind of do on a speed
up though like running a stop at 20 is
worse kind of right no you slow me down
and screen on the other side so they're
gonna slam into you so if you're
blinding us like every time I ever ran
anything I'm speeding up if you're
breaking the law
you might as well break it as hard as
you can right red late yeah okay I
always stop at all stops I do only run
red lights because I'm trying to pass it
but stops on it's been there I know it's
there yeah so reasonable she got
arrested jailed on charges including
drunk and driving speeding in marijuana
possession what about a greasy here yes
letter yeah she should be in trouble for
that right yeah
maybe she should pop up be like uh honey
maybe he gave her a ticket because he
could smell the [ __ ] stench of her
head oh the hair stink the scopes thing
scalps think that oily smell I like how
she tried to use her [ __ ] Club
membership as a way to like get out of
crime like to a bat [ __ ] it's so weird
how like openly prejudice years to you
know to me she's like you know what that
means basically saying like you know
what that means do I look like a wet
back to you you know you you don't need
a [ __ ] you don't need a DNA test to
know what she is but she just had to put
it out there yeah look at my bully I'm a
thing that dumb people she kicks it with
and how they think where was this at
South Carolina oh wait a minute
well white white people have to we have
to establish the code is in action do
you guys all have a code yeah yeah yeah
there's a white coat you have to
establish it is it like a number or
letters or is it just a well cuz you
could look at me and go oh he's white
but we don't necessarily look each other
and go oh he's white too we have to
establish like what kind of like what
kind of breeding that happened mm-hmm if
it's our breeding or not yeah they're
all breeding nah I'm like a mmm mutt
white really you don't stay in white
circles what you want the you want the
worst form of white is though is the
white person that just won't admit that
they're white I mean it's like oh I'm
you know I mean it's like I'm Irish
Scottish and I'm like two percent Native
American [ __ ] you you are why no its I'm
Italian and [ __ ] on my here huh exactly
I know exactly what you people feel like
there's a first of all using you people
yo like we were in Oklahoma we offended
some natives there because everyone that
was working at the casino were white
people and but they were like like a
couple percent native but you can't tell
you do they all look like Steve's
friends like I mean relatives they were
like a hundred percent blonde well now
my relatives are brown yeah that's true
no so even you had more money you have
actual my never more minorities in your
[ __ ] family they so we're at the
casino playing cards and [ __ ] and I made
a joke about like oh so we're all the
natives at and we're like laughing right
and then the dealer got pissed like he
was kind of upset and I was like hold on
you're native and in like the the
manager came out and he he took him off
and he scolded him and all this stuff
happened and I was like oh [ __ ] you did
that single-handed no like I think I
just offended some Native Americans that
are 99% white I've even pulled out his
Native American car to show us to like
to prove it to us because we're like no
way you're not [ __ ] Native American
he'll and there's like it's like this
pink car and I think it's like certified
by the state or whatever that is like
parfocal what you want to bet there's a
need that to justify it's like dude I'll
bet you a hundred percent the manager
pulled him away to say this he goes come
here Chad you are not [ __ ] Native
American
I could tell you you are not Native
American these chinks pay good there was
this there was this other kid that was a
part of the Asian Club he looked a
hundred percent white
you know like blond hair everything but
he was getting government aid because he
was native I love it yeah that's like
senator Elizabeth Warren she says she
has high cheekbones and so she's a
Native American maybe maybe in that part
of the world that is that is native I
don't know yeah
[Music]